この季節になると!
空気は乾燥し、
肌も乾燥。
心も、乾燥。
全体的にカサカサです。　はじめしゃちょーです。
この季節になると空気が乾燥するんで、
部屋で加湿器使う方多いと思います。
こちらの僕が使ってる加湿器なんですけれども、
うわぁ…。
これも...、
ああぁ！！
これも加湿器なんですけれども、
これはプラズマクラスターと言って、
ウイルスとかカビを退治してくれる、
結構いいやつです。
で、加湿器ってどうやって使うかと言いますと
このねぇタンク！
このタンクの中に水を入れて、
中に入れて、
ボタンを押すと、
加湿が始まるという物でございます。
私は思ってしまった！！！
普段あんまりお酒飲まないんでよくわかんないんすけども
なんかコレヤバそうだよね…
アルコールが20%
っていう、
結構高いんですよね。
かなりアルコール濃度は高いです。
このお酒...,、
おっ！
未成年のみんなは、
ホント飲んじゃだめだからね。
未成年の人買うことも許されないから。
俺、大人になってる!
え、
意外とおいしいんだけど!
あ、sちげえ全然ダメ。
苦い苦いウッウッ!
ヴオオオオオオオオオオオ!!!!
というわけで見ての通り僕、
あの
お酒が基本的に苦手なんですよ。
なんとかさ、あ、もう顔赤くね？
もう顔赤いんですけど!?
僕なんとかして、
お酒を飲まずに
この酔ったね
酔った感じを、
楽しみたいと思ったんで
今回
加湿器にお酒を入れて、
お酒で部屋を加湿したら
ひょっとしてお酒を呑まなくても
その
加湿器だけで
「酔えるんじゃないか」と
思いまして
ちょっと今回は実際にそれを
試してみようと思います。
要するに、
この部屋全体に
この酒の成分をいきわたらせるっていうことだから
一先ず入れる
宇和(これね
まず純粋に気になる。
これでもし酔えたらすげえ楽じゃん。
お酒を呑む手間が省けるっていう、
何かしながら酔えるっていう
そもそも加湿器が
ぶっ壊れるかぶっ壊れないかっていうトコもあると思うんですけど、
も！！　ま、それはやってみてからのお楽しみにしましょう！！
というわけで早速、
加湿していきましょう。
（設置と…）
いくぞ！
スイッチ
オン♥
加湿はマックスにしておきましょう
わー！×1
わー！×2
わー！×3
わー！×4
わー！×5
わー！×6
わー！×7
わー！×8
わー！×9
あっあっ
うぅ、すげえ!
ニオイする、においするよ！
わー！×10
わー！×11
すげぇ
お酒のニオイがする！
ちゃんとお酒のニオイがします。
ただこれで、
この部屋中にアルコールが
撒き散らされるかどうか
っていうとまだわかんないので、
しばらく放置して、
ホントにこれでこの部屋が
アルコールまみれになるか
っていうとちょっと調べていこうと思います(キリッ)
しばしお待ちを♥
読み込み中…
うわぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ!
すごい！すごい！！すごい！！！すごい！！！！
うわぁっ!うおっ!うわぁぁ!うわぁぁ!うわぁぁ!うわぁぁ!うわぁぁ!!!うわぁぁっ!!!うぉっ
やばい!
ハフハフはぁハフハフうおぁハフうぉぉぉ(息切れ)
うぉぉぉ　はっくしょぉーぬ　はぐしょぉん
すごいよすごいですよあの たぶんこれ
うわ!これ、やばいなこれたぶん部屋中にアルコールが散らばってる。
はい　ということで加湿するとかなり部屋中がもぉぅお酒もぉぅアルコールのにおいにまとわることが分かりました
まだ足りん！
今回さらにこちら。
アルコール濃度96％史上最強のお酒スピリタスを、
この中に入れて加湿しようと思ったん
ですけどもぉ
やばいなっと思ってネットでいろいろと調べたんですけども、
アルコールというかねぇお酒を気化するのはかなり危ないらしい。
甲次郎くらいなら別に大丈夫なんですけどぉ、
このスピリタスねこのスピリタスね　アルコール濃度96％なんで、
ほぼお酒じゃなくてもぅっ アルコールなんですょ。
このまま僕加湿器に入れて液体を気化させて、
部屋中にアルコールをまとわせて僕が入って吸うとアルコール中毒で多分...。
パッ＼(＾o＾)／
いろいろ調べたんですけども、
このアルコールを気化されると
それ吸うだけで 吸うだけでやっぱり酔うらしくて、
で、その酔うのが その酔うのがねぇ普通にお酒を飲むより1.4倍くらい早いらしくて
ネットの情報ですけどね。
1.4倍くらい早いらしいぃんで、結構危険らしいです。
増してやスピリタスなんかを加湿すると、
もぅ部屋中すっげー濃度のアルコールで満たされるんで
ほんとにかなりアルコール中毒に危険な状態らしいのでやめておきます。
まるで...、
どこかの事件で使われるトリックみたいだ。
お酒を加湿器に入れて加湿すると、
意外と部屋中お酒になるんですけども、
普通より酔いやすいのでやる人はかなり気を付けてみてください。
未成年はダメだぞ！
ぺ↓ペ↑ぺ↓ペ↑ぺ↓ペ↑ぺ↓ペ↑ぺ↓ペ↑ぺ↓ペ↑ぺ↓ペ↑ぺ↓ペ↑
本日のニュースをお伝えします。
JR高崎線でミッキー（ねずみ）がケーブルをかじったので運転見合わせ
マック、テキサスバーガー復刻で23%増収
君の名は。違法配信で初摘発
屋久島 新種植物の発見相次ぐ
PPAP Mステ出演
バス運転手 運転中にポケGO
以上で本日のニュースを終わります
うわぁっうわぁっうわぁっうぉっうぉっうぉっうわぁっうわぁっうわぁっうわぁっうわぁぁっうわぁっうぉっうっぐぇーっうびぇー(泣